القوات الاوكرانية تقصف القوات
الروسية بالصواريخ وكييف تلملم
فضائح فسادها والزلانسكي على
الاراضي البريطانية لاول مرة
والطائرات على رأس قائمة طلباته.
فهل يجازف الانجليز بخطر مواجهة
الدب الروسي وبيض للاوكرانيين
سنقف الى جانبكم مهما استغرق
الامر. اولف شولدز يطلق وعدا
مهما لاوكرانيا المناطيد قطرة في
بحر جيوش واسلحة السي وواشنطن
لبكين لن نسمح لكم بترهيبنا.
واصحاب العيون الضيقة يجيبنا برد
حازم فما الذي يجري احد عشر الف
قتيل. وثلاثة وعشرون مليون متضرر
والعداد لا يتوقف في تركيا
وسوريا فعن اي كارثة نتحدث.
مفرمة الحروب تتحرك. يوما بعد
يوم تحقق قوات روسيا تقدما بعد
اخر. بينما يمضي الاوكران لطلب
المزيد من الدعم الغربي. هنا
يحقق الروس مكاسب ميدانية في
الاسابيع الاخيرة بعدما سيطرت
قواتهم على مدينة سوريدر شمال
اوكرانيا. واخيرا السيطرة على
بلدة بحسب فرانس بريس. ليخرج
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويجو
قائلا ان انخراط حلف شمال
الاطلسي النيتو في اوكرانيا يمكن
ان يقود الى مستوى من التصعيد لا
يمكن التنبؤ به. مضيفا انهم حتى
يطيلوا امد الصراع بدأوا في
توفير اسلحة هجومية ثقيلة لحث
اوكرانيا علانية على الاستيلاء
على الاراضي الروسية وفق وكالة
رايانا فوستي الروسية. هنا يتحرك
الاوكران للرد حيث قصفت وحدة
بحرية اوكرانية بصواريخ جراد
منطقة بالقرب من مالينكا في
دونتسك التي تسيطر عليها القوات
لروسيا لتنتقل اوكرانيا الى
اصلاح صفوفها قبل اي خطوة اخرى
وبعد فضائح الفساد يعين اللواء
كيريلو بودانوف وزيرا للدفاع
وقال وزير الداخلية ان زللسكي
قرر نقل وزير الدفاع السابق
اوليكسي ريزنيكوف الى منصب وزير
الصناعات الاستراتيجية. ومن
معركة الداخل الى معارك الخارج
لكسب المساعدات. هنا طائرة تابعة
لقوات الجو الملكية البريطانية
تقل الرئيس الاوكراني زيلنسكي
هبطت بمطار ستان ستيد في لندن في
زيارة غير معلنة للمملكة
المتحدة. وهي الثانية للزلنسكي
منذ بدء الحرب بحسب شبكة بي بي
سي ليلتقي زلانسكي برئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشيسوناك بينما اجرى
لقاء اخر مع الملك تشارلز قبل ان
يلقي كلمة امام البرلمان
البريطاني. زيلانسكي شدد على اهم
حصول اوكرانيا على الاسلحة
الضرورية من الحلفاء لوقف الهجوم
الروسي وتحرير كل الاراضي
الاوكرانية المحتلة مؤقتا حسب
تعبيره. لتتعهد الحكومة
البريطانية بالمحافظة على
المستوى نفسه من المساعدة وهو
الاعلى في العالم بعد الولايات
المتحدة. تأتي زيارة زيلانسكي
الى بريطانيا في الوقت الذي اعلن
فيه سوناك عن خطط توسيع نطاق
تدريب القوات المسلحة اوكرانية
جوا وبحرا ويشمل ذلك طياري
المقاتلات ومشاة البحرية كجزء من
الاستثمار طويل الامد في جيشهم.
ليستغل زلينسكي الرغبة
البريطانية ويدعو لندن الى
تسليمهم طائرات مقاتلة لكسب
الحرب ضد روسيا. وقال اطلبوا
منكم ومن العالم طائرات مقاتلة
لاوكرانيا اجنحة من اجل الحرية.
ومن بريطان الى امريكا. القى
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن خطاب
حالة الاتحاد السنوي امام مجلسي
النواب والشيوخ في العاصمة
واشنطن ليستعرض اهم القضايا
الداخلية والخارجية للبلاد ويشرح
سياسة ومواقف الادارة الامريكية
تجاه مختلف الشؤون والخلافات.
هناك تعهد بايدن بدعم بلاده
لاوكرانيا مهما استغرق الامر
لمساعدتها على صد الغزو الروسي
لاراضيها. قال بايدن متوجها
بحديثه الى سفيرة اوكرانيا لدى
واشنطن اوكسانا ماركاروفا التي
كانت حاضرة سنقف الى جانبكم مهما
استغرق الامر. امتنا تعمل من اجل
مزيد من الحريات والكرامة
والسلام ليس فقط في اوروبا بل في
كل مكان. لكن الى متى سيستمر
دعمكم هذا يا هؤلاء. وبين هذا
وذاك ظهر المستشار ليؤكد ان
موسكو لن تنتصر في الحرب وان
اوكرانيا تنتمي الى اوروبا مضيفا
ان بوتين لن يحقق اهدافه في
الحرب في اوكرانيا لا في ساحة
المعركة ولا من خلال فرض معاهدة
سلام حسب قوله. وتابع قائلا
تنتمي لاوكرانيا الى اوروبا
مستقبلها في الاتحاد الاوروبي.
وهذا الوعد مهم. الصين شوكة
ابتلاعها. كل يغني على ليلاه في
الوقت الحاضر ولكن واشنطن تغني
بمنافسة التنين الصيني. لا يمر
الليل والنهار على الادارة
الامريكية دون تذكر بكين. نعم يا
سادة هنا الرئيس بايدن يقول ان
الولايات المتحدة لن تسمح للصين
بترهيبها. لكنه اكد في الوقت
نفسه ان واشنطن لا تسعى الى نزاع
مع بكين ليتابع قائلا تسيء
فهمنا. كما اظهرنا بوضوح الاسبوع
الماضي اذا هددت الصين سيادتنا
فسنعمل على حماية بلادنا وفعلنا
ذلك. في اشارة الى اسقاط الجيش
الامريكي لمنطاد صيني السبت
قبالة سواحل ولاية كارولينا
الجنوبية. لكن هل يعد اسقاط تلك
البالونة انجازا يا هذا؟ الرد
الصيني لم يتأخر وعلى لسان
المنطقة وزارة الخارجية الصينية
ماولينج التي قالت انهم سيدافعون
بحزم عن سيادة الصين وامنها
ومصالحها التنموية داعية
الولايات المتحدة الى العمل مع
الصين لدفع العلاقات الصينية
الامريكية الى مسار التنمية
الصحية والمستقرة. القلق
الامريكي يتواصل والمنطاد هو ما
يحير الامريكان. هنا اجهزة
الاستخبارات الامريكية تربط بين
المنطاد الذي اسقطته الولايات
المتحدة وبين برنامج تجسس واسع
النطاق تديره القوات الجوية لجيش
التحرير الشعبي الصيني واصفين
الامر بانه جهد جبار كما بدأ
المسئولون الامريكيون في احاطة
الحلفاء والشركاء الذين استهدفوا
بمثل هذا التصرف حول ماهيته بحسب
صحيفة واشنطن بوست. ليعود
المسؤولون الامريكيون موضحين ان
هذه المناطيد تعمل بدل عن
المسيرات وبتكلفة اقل بكثير كما
يصعب اكتشافها من قبل الاعداء
وقد اطلقت الصين المناطيد على
مسارات الطيران التي نقلتها في
جميع انحاء العالم بحسب الصحيفة
الامريكية. الاحداث والتطورات.
تتواصل عمليات البحث عن ناجين
تحت الانقاض بعد اكثر من يومين
من الزلزال الذي اودى بحياة اكثر
من احد عشر الف في تركيا وسوريا
وشرد اعدادا لا تحصى في ظل البرد
القارس. ويا له من زلزال دمر
الحجر والشجر واباد البشر. تعلن
منظمة الصحة العالمية خشيتها من
ان يصل عدد الضحايا الى عشرين
الف قتيل. وقد قدرت عدد
المتضررين من الزلزال بثلاثة
وعشرين مليونا فعن اي ارقام
مهولة نتحدث. الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب زار منطقة الزلزال في كهرمان
مرعش التركية ليعلن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى في تركيا الى تسعة الاف
وسبعة وخمسين والجرحى الى اثنين
وخمسين الفا وتسعمائة وتسعة
وسبعين. فيما بلغ عدد المباني
المنهارة ستة الاف واربعمائة
واربعة واربعين. والاعداد قابلة
للزيادة خلال الساعات والايام
القادمة. في سوريا ويا لحال سور
البائس ارتفع عدد ضحايا الزلزال
في عموم البلاد الى الفين
وتسعمائة واثنين. وبلغ عدد
المصابين اكثر من خمسة الاف ما
يرفع حصيلة القتلى الاجمالية في
البلدين الى اكثر من احد عشر
الفا. لتعلن فرق الدفاع المدني
المعروفة باسم الخوذ البيضاء
شمالي سوريا ان عدد الضحايا مرشح
للارتفاع في ظل صعوبات في الوصول
الى بعض المناطق المنكوبة ونقص
الامكانات والمعدات التقيلة
وبرودة الطقس. يواجه النظام
الصحي البريطاني اكبر اضراب عن
العمل في تاريخه اذ قرر عشرات
الاف الممرضين والممرضات
والمسعفين التوقف عن العمل في
اليوم نفسه. مصر تعلن عن ارتفاع
الاحتياطي من الذهب لاول مرة
لتغدو الثالثة عالميا بحسب
مستشار وزير التموين لشؤون صناعة
الذهب المصري. زلزال تركيا
وسوريا تزداد وروسيا تزيد من
سيطرتها على الاراضي الاوكرانية
والصين كابوس يتجدد للامريكان.